as a Disney princess Wednesday reminds
us a lot of Belle she's completely
obsessed with books and willing to
accept things even if they look a little
strange her trusty sidekick would have
to be thing of course glad you're ending
loyalty to me which might just be one of
the sickest pets that we can think of
she's true to herself and she's no
Damsel in Distress waiting around to be
saved making her a lot more like this
new age of Disney Princesses than you
would think plus she comes with her own
castle in the form of Nevermore Academy
when it comes to design she'd have the
big eyes and bangs of Cinderella with
her hair obviously dyed black her
princess gown would probably be
something like the one that she wore
during her iconic dance sequence